Braunwald, Fiesch, Grindelwald and Marbach are the Swiss Meccas for paragliding.
Here, your dream about flying can become reality.
You can fly high above the clouds...
...in seriously breathtaking landscapes.
You lift off above the valley and glide in elegant circles weightlessly through the air.
The freedom above the clouds seem limitless.
If you have never flown before, that is no problem!
Grindelwald's professional state-licensed pilots are motivated to impart the sensation...
...of flying to people without prior knowledge of paragliding.
It is not only their job but also their passion.
Marbach is an El dorado for paragliding and gliders.
The new launching pad and flying school are right by the cable car.
Beginner and advanced courses are always available.
Enjoy the mountains from the view of the local eagles.
Let yourself be carried off into the world of weightlessness...
...and you will realize that the oldest dream of humanity has become true.